[Music]
yes he is the top of s er of mechanical
engineering a bio engineering here at
MIT I have to say that one of my most
exciting experiences in first coming to
MIT five years ago was actually going
into lab if you want to see information
being used with all of the aspects to go
check it out but today he's going to
talk to us about work that's going on at
the bio instrumentation lab I don't look
we know but we have a big effort to
start up a large by automation
instrumentation program here
and that's how many of the techniques
that people were talking about yesterday
from instrumentation and getting
information
we'll probably have the greatest
application over the next half century
or so what I'm gonna do is talk about
really two areas that are going on in
our laboratory the development of
biomimetic materials largely centered
around conducting polymers and the other
is the development of a small walking
autonomous robot called the nano Walker
and you'll see how these two themes we
hope to merge them in the next couple of
years so that we'll be fabricating a
nano Walker out of the biomimetic
materials so my co-authors are silver
Mattel John Madden Peter Madden and we
have John Madden here today next phase
so one of the objective objective ZAR
laboratory is to try and automate the
process by which new materials are
discovered be they new drugs or new
interesting superconducting materials
new actuator materials and what we are
working towards is the notion of having
in the one instrument technologies for
synthesizing materials as well as
analyzing their anisotropic material
properties be they electrical thermal
mechanical optical acoustic chemical and
so on are all orchestrated by molecular
and continuum modeling techniques and a
an objective rational approach to
instrumentation design and modification
of those designs and modeling algorithms
as a function of what is measured next
now what are the typical sort of
operations you might be using when
working with new materials typically
you'll have a material you take it -
perhaps a scanning tunneling microscope
for an atomic force microscope you might
do some laser optical microscopy measure
mechanical impedance
electrical impedance you might do some
3d micro fabrication some nano
fabrication some mm Epsom Ramon
spectroscopy and so on and so on at the
moment these are all conceived of as
separate instruments and you would take
a specimen from one instrument to the
next what we're working towards is the
notion of having basically the one
platform for implementing the this range
of functionalities and we're calling
that platform the Nano Walker the Nano
Walker will eventually be an autonomous
device carrying its own computer it has
a minimum of 12 degrees of freedom and
as you'll see shortly it's capable of
Nano stepping in fact it can move with
sub nanometer increments but the idea is
to use that as a platform to implement
these different tasks and we're not
conceiving of the one nano walker
implementing all of these but rather you
would have a version of a nano Walker
which would be acting as an atomic force
microscope another version for a micro
injection and so on next so this is the
current size of the nano Walker and I
have one right here we are in the
process of making them autonomous in the
videos you're about to see you'll see a
tether where we bring the energy into
the nano Walker as well as the
information to control it but we're
working very hard to try and make the
device autonomous without tethers next
how dare you just see it rotating and
you'll see here that we're able to get
the nano Walker to move quite quickly
and bear in mind that here we have steps
that are down to sub nanometer level if
we wish here the steps are many tens of
nano
meters up to hundreds of nanometres per
step and we've been able to make the
steps up to 4,000 per second so we've
been able to get these devices to move
very rapidly next now some of the
functionalities that you can build in
are for example you can use a micro
laser to trap particles and conceivably
use the nano Walker to move those
particles around and if we can place the
cursor on the one that's now trapped so
there's an infrared laser trapping that
particle and we're able to move it
around in three dimensions so the nano
Walker is conceived of is not only being
usable for making traditional sort of
physical contact with a material but
here we're exerting forces on materials
using photon momentum next here's an
example of a version of the technology
that were using in the nano Walker prior
to the nano walkers ability to move with
four legs and here we're scanning in
three dimensions over the surface of a
graphite surface and on your right we
have an image that's one nanometer by
one nanometer and the step size there is
ten Pico meters so you can clearly see
the individual atoms there so the Nano
Walker is koval of moving down with
minimum motions of about ten kilometers
and it can move up to about a meter
workspace next now when we look at the
nano Walker we see really a very large
difference between the way in which that
device is fabricated versus the way in
which nature fabricates it's Auto Namas
devices and there you see a water flea
roughly a millimeter in size and a
single bacteria roughly one enormous are
one or two nano one or two micrometers I
should say in size so what we have to
ask ourselves is what is the main
difference between the way in which we
would
Kait the nana walker is an engineering
system versus the way in which nature
fabricates its systems next and so on
your left there I have some of the
salient features of current engineering
practice where we normally use low
molecular weight materials such as
copper iron aluminum silicon and so on
existing engineering systems are
characterized by separate manufacture
and assembly think of the notebook
computers that I see around the room
here the CPU the various disks and
actuators the case and display are all
separately manufactured and then
assembled
whereas in nature things are grown their
co fabricated and of course nature's
materials are high molecular weight most
engineering materials the material
properties are isotropic thermal
conductivity is much the same in all
directions electrical conductivity
pretty much the same in all directions
optical transmission normally pretty
much the same in all directions whereas
biological materials are normally highly
anisotropic and it's very clear that
nature uses those anisotropic material
properties in fabricating biological
systems and then the other thing that
characterizes characterizes existing
engineering systems is that if for
example you create a micro actuator such
as a piezoelectric device shape-memory
alloy actuator magnetostrictive device
that's really a bulk material phenomena
whereas if you look for example at
muscle that is a mechanism down to the
molecular level it's literally a nano
stepper a molecular linear stepping
motor and it's a mechanism it's no more
a bulk material than for example an
internal combustion engine might be
considered a bulk material so biological
systems are really very different and we
have to ask ourselves is it conceivable
to fabricate biological engineering
systems using similar principles next
now this
a particular taxonomy here is due to
Seth Lloyd and Seth was thinking well on
the one hand and living systems we can
say there's energy and on the other hand
we've got Energy Information on the one
hand and energy on the other and if we
look at the various things that
biological systems do will they acquire
information in the form of vision and
and acoustics and touch and so on and we
acquire energy by drinking and and so on
we store information we store energy
energy is largely stored in the form of
ATP very high energy density chemical
storage mechanism we transfer
information via neurons for example and
we transfer energy via blood vessels we
transform and generate we compute and we
also do that with with energy and that
muscles converts stored chemical energy
to mechanical output with surprisingly
high efficiency and of course we dispose
of information and we dispose of energy
next so when we look at at biomimetic
systems we can say is it conceivable to
create a class of materials from which
we could create intelligent systems with
the ability to Co fabricate and grow and
to have an isotropic material properties
but where the different subsystems could
mimic those in a biological system that
is to say we want to be able to acquire
information acquire energy store
information store energy transfer
transform and generate and dispose and
so what I want I want to talk about in
the next few minutes are our and others
attempts to create a class of materials
biomimetic materials biological like
materials having a good percentage of
these characteristics here I regard that
until we have most of these
characteristics here we're not in a
position
to create a biomimetic autonomous
intelligent system a biological robot if
you like next so here is some of the
activity going on in our lab in this
area we have work going on to create
powerful actuators out of these
biomimetic materials who work with and
they're called conducting polymers low
bandwidth trance transistors I'll talk
about some very exciting work where
we've managed to transmit not only
information through this material but
also significant amounts of energy
energy storage and sensors of various
sorts and so on and so forth so you can
see a list and black.there of what we're
working on in blue are obviously the
counterparts that you'll find in nature
and in red we have some of the caveats
here and that the transistors at the
moment are very slow and some of the
acoustic devices have got low bandwidth
and so on and so forth so you have to
think of this as early days in the
development of this technology next so
basically this is just one example of
one conducting polymer but it can be
coaxed into various forms and when for
example it's in one of its forms a zero
percent oxidation state it's electrical
conductivity is extraordinarily low but
it can be switched into another state a
50 percent oxidation state where the
electrical conductivity can go up by as
much as 10 or 11 orders of magnitude
theoretically so these are materials
where they're salient material
properties in this case electrical
conductivity can be switched over an
enormous range and furthermore that
material property often can be very very
different in different directions so for
example you can make a wire of this
material where the electrical
conductivity in the polymer chain
Direction can be
enormous and in the other two orthogonal
directions it can be extremely small
next so we grow these materials in the
lab electrochemically next and here's an
example of one of the applications of
the technology it turns out that if you
strain the material you can set it up to
act as a strain gauge a useful sensor
for many applications next and here's
just some results and we found that
we've got moderately high gauge factors
in the order of about five so there's an
example of a relative a sensitive force
or strain transducer made out of these
materials
what about computation can we create a
transistor out of these materials well
indeed there's a long history at MIT of
creating conducting polymer transistors
in the past they were largely fabricated
on silicon or glass substrates we've
been building them on entirely pretty
much out of polymers and they share
characteristics with FETs in that we'll
have a source drain a gate Oh usually
these are for terminal devices next and
here's an example where we're switching
this transistor from a state in which
it's conducting to a non conducting
state and there you see we have not
achieved the theoretical 10 to the 10 or
10 to the 11 fold change in resistivity
is yet next the switching times of these
devices are governed by different
equations from traditional silicon based
transistors next and at the moment
they're relatively slow so if for
example you fabricate these materials in
bulk the transistors only have a
bandwidth of about 1 Hertz if you go
down to about 50 nanometers 10 kilohertz
has been achieved
and certainly if you go down to thin
molecular layers speeds of one megahertz
are achievable and they're so this is
not a technology that would compete with
silicon for raw speed but when you think
of it the neurons in your own brain have
a relatively low bandwidth and yet they
confer an advantage by virtue of the
fact that you can fabricate them in 3d
next what about creating wires turns out
that these materials by Ohm's law
remarkably well over a wide range so you
can transmit information through them
next but the question that we asked
ourselves was it possible to transmit
significant amount of energy through
these conducting polymer wires now
typically when you design an electric
motor and you're pushing it to the limit
your figure you can pump about ten to
the seven amps per square meter through
a a non water-cooled
electric motor here we're achieving
basically a third of that
so we're within a third basically or
within an order of magnitude of what you
can push through copper an interesting
difference is that the density of copper
is about eight times greater than these
polymers so in point of fact we are
equivalent via some measures volumetric
measures to copper and silver at room
temperature the very interesting
possibility is that theoretically it's
clear that we should be able to go way
past this point
but we're very excited that we have now
achieved very significant energy
densities through these materials next
and also we've created super capacitors
out of these materials they have a low
bandwidth very low bandwidth but we can
store something in the or we've achieved
something in the order of ten to the
five farad's per kilogram that's orders
and orders of magnitude greater than for
example a tantalum capacitor that is
normally regarded as as a high energy
density capacitor
next actuators here we show the
multi-layer configuration for the
actuators next and we are working with a
variety of conducting polymer materials
and here's a very interesting one we
started to work with collec serine which
holds the promise of achieving large
strains much larger than we're achieving
at the moment next and so far we've been
walking working to push the act of
strains the contractions achieved by
these materials up as well as their
bandwidth next and also creating
versions of it that can operate in room
temperature and an air you'll notice
that the voltages here are very small so
these are not like piezoelectric
materials where you need to use voltages
in the hundreds of volt range we can get
these things to things to contract
actually with less than 1 volt next and
bandwidths are also somewhat equivalent
to what you would find in muscle so
bandwidths between 1 and 20 Hertz next
so we'll show you one of the actuators
oscillating at 1 Hertz and there's a
square wave oscillation now if we can go
down to the 10 Hertz
so that is now equivalent to fast
skeletal muscle that's a bilayer and if
we can now go to the lower one here
you'll see a linear actuator contracting
and causing a small arm to move so we've
got a cantilever there and so what you
see there is this material here
fabricated in a laboratory we put a
voltage across it it contracts and we're
driving that cantilever there next slide
please
so the act of stress is we're achieving
here are a remarkably high we've
achieved in the order of 30 mega
Pascal's next are the strains we achieve
are typically four or five percent but
we've achieved up to 18 percent next and
power to mass is also moderately high
and expected to be much greater next and
the efficiency also is surprisingly high
it's about equivalent to muscle next and
we're working to produce over the summer
a complete reflex loop containing
actuator sensor simple computation to
create a closed-loop servo system server
controlling the actuator with respect to
strain that if you like is the first
building block the reflex loop is the
first building block in nature next so
now it's it's our objective to produce
in the form of the Nano Walker a form of
internal Walker at some point
incorporating this technology next so
when we look to the future we are
expecting probably in about two or three
years to start replacing some of the
more traditional technologies we have in
the Nano Walker with some of these
biomimetic materials thank you very much
[Applause]
yes we fabricate these ourselves by the
way and we're working very hard on
creating a three-dimensional fabrication
system to Co fabricate the actuators the
transistors the sensors the energy
storage delivery and so on to co
fabricate them together one of the
ironies here is that it may indeed turn
out that we use the Nano Walker the
existing nano Walker as the technology
for creating the future nano Walker's
out of these new materials yes well when
you have a if you're talking about how
many cycles we can go through for these
devices or do you mean if we look out in
the future - well we're seeing these as
direct competitors with silicon based
MEMS technology silicon is a great
technology for manipulating information
but terrible for manipulating energy
you can't the the capacitors you
implement in silicon have very low
energy density the electrostatic
actuators are very weak so here we have
a technology with an extraordinarily
powerful actuator technology very high
energy density super capacitors so we
can not only manipulate information lb8
at low bandwidth but we can manipulate
energy and that really puts us way ahead
of silicon if you want to both
manipulate energy information as well as
energy which of course is what
biological systems do
unless I think on that which is I think
that this work shows very clearly how if
you're operating in third small scales
of micro scale and the nanoscale that
the trade-offs you cannot move
information without moving energy around
that you cannot make energy to make
energetic processes happen without
moving information around as well now
these two things are combined with each
other in a way at the micro scale in
which in a way they're not at the macro
scale we can essentially completely a
couple information processing from
energetics it's actually reminds me of
almost when you get down to this small
scale it's almost as if you're turning
to having a car with a well what I
mentioned with the mechanical government
right the information processing parts
of the system are themselves mechanical
so you actually have to look very
carefully the trade-off between the
information and enter
it's by no means clear to us that we
necessarily want to use the transistor
for information there's not a reason
here why we couldn't can see that
building a mechanical computer because
if you look at the energy involved in
living the Parliament there are some
situations we compute knowing energies
than is currently used for the gate in
silicon based technology and I'll remind
you that when the actin-myosin
Prospero general muscle moves it's
consuming about 10 to the minus 20
joules in making that step so if you
think of that as potentially mechanical
computer it's about 10 to the 7 fold
less energy in moving that molecule than
current silicon technology
consume stepping up gates in a fast take
you to the World Cup your early Earth
was involved with survivors
yes and I know we're getting on time
here very gossipy one of our challenges
of the next year is to give these things
to be able to move upside down
and when a fly moves upside down it's
actually creating chemical bonds with
the surface it's got a controllable
stickiness and we would like something
similar here so that we could move
around upside down or we just professor
of the de lab and we're very lucky in
mechanical engineering that he's
consented also to be volunteering I was
very happy about this because in fact
one of the things that Joe works on in
addition to what he's going to tell you
about today is quantum computing so but
today he's going to tell you about
fabrication more conventional but still
very unconventional computing devices
okay actually could we
yes
okay it's free pleasure honor not to be
here and I want to just tell you a
little bit about some of the
technologies we're developing to build
computers and other devices that we
associate with the Information Age in
new ways and pictured up here is a kind
of cartoonish figure of what we envision
the famine of the future to be and
basically if you can imagine a little
desktop printer a little desktop device
and you download from the web say a
design for a Pentium 3 and press a
button and out comes working Pentium 3
and I'll tell you a little bit about how
we're doing this in a minute more
broadly what we're interested in doing
is enabling the manufacturer of
information devices in a in a way that
hasn't really fully been brought to the
floor which is continuous manufacturing
as opposed to really making things one
at a time and this is kind of a list of
some of the things that we've
demonstrated to date in terms of being
able to make on roll-to-roll processes
and continuous process of what we would
call printable technology and for each
of these we've actually had to develop
completely new chemistry's or completely
novel chemistry's or ways of doing
things in order to reach the point that
we're interested in doing obviously as
Ian eloquently laid out we need new ways
to make logic and new ways to make
computation and this is true not just
for cost reasons not just to make things
on flexible plastic as I'll show you in
a minute but we really want to make new
types of architectures new topologies
that are not enabled by current fab
techniques specifically the ability to
go very high device counts and to go to
very high interconnect counts between
devices in a way that is not possible
today secondly in order to have
universal logic obviously we need memory
in addition to logic
then there's some other things that we
as humans like to have for instance
display we'd like to be able to
visualize some of the information buried
in the computation that we're carrying
out and then finally an appropriate for
mechanical engineering of course is the
ability to do micro electromechanical
systems in this case we've called this
Pam's which are a printed
electromechanical system I'll show you
some very early examples of that ok so
right
very briefly this is some older work
that we've done but I'll just put up one
or two slides we were interested in how
to build a display in a completely new
way basically
by printing and the standard route to
making displays liquid crystal displays
as you may know it's very similar to the
way we make chips the cost of a fab a
Gen 3 fab for making LCD displays is in
excess of a billion and a half dollars
and displays are made roughly a couple
at a time these days about four or six
displays at a time on large pieces of
glass and our question was how we could
go from that to actually being able to
print a little machine onto a surface
that would act as act as a display and
not only any display but actually get us
to the best properties that that that
that we thought theoretically could be
achieved meaning the lowest current draw
a purely field effect material if you
will liquid crystal display as you may
know needs to be driven with a
alternating or an AC current in order to
prevent ion migration we wanted
something that was purely a field effect
something that would draw a few nano
amps per square centimeter and so what
we came up with is a very simple system
extraordinarily simple system we have a
little micro capsule that we create
using a bulk chemistry and interfacial
polymerization the captures inside of it
some nanoparticles and these
nanoparticles have surface groups that
have been appended to them and these
surface groups are covalently bond to
those nanoparticles and they impart to
each particle
roughly about 10 electrons worth of
charge and then if we put an external
field here we can simply flip these
position of these little particles visa
V or I and create a display and if you
keep distances small enough and so forth
you can actually get things to go pretty
quickly this is a very early video of
this and I hope it's I hope it's not too
dark so this is gonna be a lens system
that's going to go below the surface and
in the next frame so this is some of
this ink that we've coated on to a piece
of plastic in this case and now we're
applying a 1 Hertz pulse or 1 Hertz
waveform to this and in the next couple
frames you can see what I mean by
printing a little machine we that the
motion of this is actually like a little
cat Cyrus and it turns out that if you
stop the electric field you can stop
that cat's iris just about anywhere that
you want along that cycle so of any
opening it so you can make different
images appear as I said this is a very
kind of early system and you can see
some imperfections in that we've we've
gotten a lot better in the chemistry
that we've been able to create and
here's just a little example well the
the the external capsule yeah the the
typically the smallest capsule that we
create here is about 10 microns or so
and the internal nanoparticles are about
a hundred nanometers or so depending on
which which color were interested in an
important aspect is is shown here
and you can see that it's really the
electric field that defines the image as
opposed to these capsules unfortunately
I don't have the most recent picture but
in most recent chemistry's these
capsules when they go down onto a
surface actually close pack and
self-assemble into close packed arrays
there the chemistry is conformable
enough that it can actually tile the
surface and then it's really the
electric field as you can see
here that defines the image as opposed
to the capsule placement for instance so
this is an extraordinarily inexpensive
way to make displays a very large size
the other property that I should mention
it as I alluded to is if you remove the
electric field completely then the image
will just stay there and so you have
this aspect of of by stability this is
just a test device showing resolutions
of about a hundred dpi or so and the
best resolutions we've achieved are in
excess of 250 dpi that just shows some
of the the thickness and so forth so
this is the front end the visual end of
devices that we might want to make and
then of course we need to be able to
make logic and and computation in the in
the background and so what we were
interested in is taking as a taking as a
starting point the ability to make an
information appliance like a laptop for
instance and there's actually several
different hierarchies of logic that we
require there so if you think about the
display again a liquid crystal display
in in a laptop the backplane the
so-called TFT or the thin film
transistor backplane doesn't need to be
extraordinarily good it needs to have
mobilities of about one centimeter
square per volt second which is
achievable by using amorphous silicon so
all of the transistors the million
transistors on the back of your glass
can be so-called amorphous silicon or
amorphous silicon quality then when you
think about what's driving all of those
pixels those are the drivers and those
need to be a little bit better
typically we'd like to be poly silicon
those are about a hundred times as fast
or need to be about a hundred times as
fast then of course we have a CPU which
we want to be the best that it can be
and these days that's about a gigahertz
and to get there we need to use single
crystal silicon and in the future we
need to go beyond that to
to materials like silicon germanium and
then of course if you have an RF modem
for instance at 5.6 gigahertz then
you're already using a heterogeneous
semiconductor like Silicon germanium so
we have this entire hierarchy and what
we were interested in doing is enabling
the ability to make all of those logic
devices by printing but to enable that
entire hierarchy up to very fast speed
so we wanted a single technology that
could get us all the way from low speeds
up to very high speeds in fact speeds in
principle faster than you could do with
a single semiconductor like Silicon so
in order to do that the the best
materials that we know of
obviously are inorganic materials these
are materials that are processed in a
normal fab now I should mention that
when you tip when you when you process a
Pentium the time to process that Pentium
is long typically you start with say a
12 inch wafer that goes into the fab and
as a very minimum you're talking about
two weeks of 24 hour a day 7 day a week
processing before Pentiums emerge from
that you have on the order of 49 or 50
math counts each mask the wafer goes
into vacuum comes out of vacuum gets a
cmp polish step and so forth and they're
just extraordinary number of steps
involved in that and so our question was
can we get there without doing any
lithography at all but being careful
that the final product that we deliver
is indistinguishable to you from what
comes out of the fab so what we
developed was a chemistry that we
published last year in science we're for
the first time we took we were able to
create nanoclusters these are clusters
that have about 80 atoms of an inorganic
semiconductor in them and then to put on
the apices of that nano cluster what we
call leaving groups or organic groups
that can self-assemble these clusters
once they're self-assembled onto a
surface those organic groups pop off and
create a single crystal and film and
this is this is really the key to being
able to liquid process transistors or
print transistors which are
indistinguishable at the end of the day
from what comes out of a fem
so actually it's not really possible to
to view the site these clusters with
conventional te tems
their size is on the order of a
nanometer or so these are some these are
some nano clusters which are a little
bit bigger than this one key that I that
I really haven't mentioned is the fact
that each of those clusters has to be
really for this to work has to be of an
exact size you need a monitor dispersed
distribution but at any rate when we
take this material and put it down onto
a surface as mentioned and so here's a
little crystal model of this four to six
semiconductor as mentioned when they
come down onto a surface hundreds of
these clusters come together their
organic group pops off and they form a
crystal and sheets here out of which we
can build transistors and really the
remarkable thing at least that we
thought when when we first saw this was
that the clusters don't come together in
an arbitrary orientation but actually
all of the crystal planes line up which
of course is the key to making
high-quality devices so here are some of
the first devices that we've made and
these these these very first devices
were already the best by by more than an
order of magnitude of any kind of
transistor that people have ever printed
and the first as far as we know printed
in organic transistors and so the other
thing that I should mention is that once
that crystalline plane comes together it
can it's the same material as came out
of a fab we've done all types of
backscatter electrons surface probes and
and volumetric probes and it
far as we can tell there's no organic
content left and so these materials can
withstand very high temperature after
the first printing so how do we take
some of that material and and start to
print it or how well can we do when we
start to print this and so this is not
this turns out to be pretty
straightforward we can take some of
these materials and and really the magic
is in the material in terms of its
ability to come together and we can take
some some printing blocks not these
particular ones but ones that have
patterns on them that are appropriate
for transistors and we've made two at
this point we've made every component
inside of a full-up ship including
capacitors resistors in fact the aspect
ratio of resistors that we can make is
is huge I'll show you in a second we can
print down to 200 nanometers and we can
print resistors that just go for several
inches unbroken with that resolution
yeah
yeah the the the edge versus I'll show
you I'll show you some data yeah in a
second okay so actually here's some
single layered structures and here's
here's some structures that are a few
microns we can print captured structures
we one very important aspect which I'll
show you in a second is the ability to
print vias because you want to be able
to go from layer to layer to layer
without any lithographic step I hear
some 200 nanometer structures we've done
recently some hundred nanometer
structures and so the the the integrity
of the of the line we can build working
devices at 200 nanometers with full
insulation between lines the integrity
of the line is probably good to at least
50 nanometers okay so one very important
aspect that I want to point out and then
we've we've pointed out it at a recent
conference is our ability to print
multi-layer structures the self
planarization property of this chemistry
and that's extraordinarily important
we've actually printed using some some
other technology a very large number of
layers in fact as many as 400 layers or
so and the the real difference between
this and say vacuum deposition is vacuum
deposition of a material like silicon is
conformal it drapes over every structure
you have for that reason you need to
remove it from vacuum and do a cmp
polish down this technology this
chemistry is self planar right self
planar rising to a very good degree and
so we can simply print multi stack
structures without having to do any etch
step between layers and that that's a
very important property for being able
to build three-dimensional structures
and logic here are just some more
printed transistors and recently we've
printed I will start with our two six
materials you can also print photo
conductor arrays and so forth or I
should say photo transistor arrays okay
so here's here's just a last
thing I haven't really been specific
about what substrate we're printing on
but many people are interested in being
able to have transistors that are on
flexible substrates like piece of
plastic and so forth and so yeah lots of
the work that we do is on thin plastic
films and you could imagine having
little displays that you can roll up put
in your pocket and so forth and our hope
is is to be able to have a technologist
as cheap enough that these transistors
are actually disposable they can perform
some function for some brief period of
time and then you can dispose them this
is a set of ring oscillators actually
each one of these is is several hundred
transistors okay so I'm not sure what my
my time is like I have four minutes okay
let me let me just briefly these are
some work we've done in RFID tags let me
briefly just talk about our work in
printing little machines and this is in
a very kind of early stage this is some
results that we just presented at I
Triple E MEMS in Tokyo in January basic
idea is to use the same chemistry in
this case we're just showing that we can
put this into an inkjet head and so
these are this is a nearly conventional
inkjet head and we can print out the
same kind of self-assembling chemistry
onto a surface and again we're going to
print out multiple layers to create some
function in this case we've created this
is a six layer printing and my apologies
here let's see if any of these
so this is a little linear drive motor
we're actually interested in making some
little microfluidic chips by printing
and in this case we have some little
nanoparticles that we're bidding in two
different bins and you can imagine that
on each one of these bins they carry out
some chemical reaction and this is a way
to create the same kinds of steps that
you might have on the bench top where
you take a beaker and pour it into this
beaker and this speaker goes into this
beaker and so forth but again what we're
interested in here is something that
we've printed flexible and disposable so
if this will let me out okay the other
thing I want to say is that as you
probably are aware the same limitation
that I mentioned in terms of creating
three-dimensional structures in silicon
and a standard fab for logic also
applies to MEMS the very best in the
world is is work done at Sandia National
Labs five layers of silicon which is
really extraordinary machines but
because of that we really think when
we're building MEMS in mostly in terms
of two dimensional structures about the
simplest structure we can build this is
a heater where we have a higher current
density in this arm than in this arm
this was built by a student of mine
using conventional silicon techniques so
typically we're thinking about building
horizontal or structures in the plane
the functioning of this is is very
straightforward you just put a current
through this current density is higher
here than here and you can get this
thing to to move okay so one of the
prospects of using this kind of
chemistry that I mentioned is the
ability to go up into the three
dimension up into the third dimension
and build vertical structures and so
here we've built this is by inkjet
printing now the reason this looks like
it's floating in mid-air is we first
printed a release layer and then we
printed a heater and this is a different
heat waitor than then people have made
before it's it's a vertical heat waiter
where you have 40 layers here and 140
layers here so this is building built up
out of claim this is an example we
printed 140 different layers it's
another it's another view of in one
reason you might be interested in inkjet
manufacturing of MEMS is to cover large
surfaces like airplane wings and and so
forth this is a very crude version
before we really had our printing
technology down but you can see if we
put a little current into this we can we
can make those things go and now my
student is making large arrays of these
devices so with those couple of comments
all in thanks very much that teach
waiter the best frequencies we've gotten
are not particularly fast they're on the
order of 10 Hertz or so but well if
that's built by inkjet and so our
resolution is really limited there the
cue of the materials that we can put
down actually that was are made from
metal nanoclusters so the cue is not as
high we're now making them by with
semiconductor nanoparticles that should
be in different from them so 10
kilohertz those kinds of ring over you
know 25 to 50 micron displacements
yes first that's right our laboratory we
developed a chemistry we developed a we
develop a chemistry for synthesizing
particles at that at that size and they
are inorganic particles that have
organic capping groups that's right
[Applause]
George's one of the newest members of
our department and about the strength of
our department of optics optics at MIT
in any rate that's traditionally not the
localized in any department they're
great people all over the place though
perhaps the research lab for life I
think that that's just wrong these
places however now I think it's very
fair to say given the recent parts of
like that that we now have the strongest
optics group and MIT but considerably
and that as you see I think that one of
the things that we've seen is that over
the past couple of days as if optical
methods are really key for doing lots of
the instrumentation and manipulation at
small scales
that's really not you can't beat a
photon for getting information from here
to there unless of course we wanted to
walk along a muscle fiber as it was
suggesting then I
anyway George is going to tell us today
about optical imaging of three and four
dimensions colored and SpaceX all right
so so I guess it's great to to succeed
the speakers like Ian and Joe because a
lot of the things that they said sort of
set the pace for my talk as well so let
me first outline what I'm going to talk
about first of all I'll talk a little
bit about optics vision information and
what is the relevance between
information and optics and then I'll
talk a little bit about what I do so
since I'm talked about in detail let me
not go through it now at the end last
night I made one slide on educational
initiatives in the optics area because
yes there were quite a few questions
about how you deal with information
education mechanical engineering and
then will conclude all right so so
optics has been a very exciting field
and in fact it's also a very old field
so if you look at here you would
calculate that it's about you know about
3000 years old that people started
realizing that light is very important
because that's how we see and that's how
we can also do other things like set
things on fire and so on and so forth so
they figured it out and they started
working on how to use light and how to
understand light and yet even though
it's such an old field it seems to
always be exciting because every once in
a while and you discover it happens and
you know that sets up a new revolution
and this seems to keep happening so let
me go through very briefly some
historical facts so apparently the first
recorded the use of light for
information was by the ancient Egyptians
who knew apparently that light rays
travel in straight lines so they use
this fact to measure the radius of the
earth by looking at sunlight through a
well of some sort so let me go through
this like a high school exercise I shall
not go through this but so this was
quite quite some time ago
then ancient Greeks a new geometry very
well they also knew about the properties
of light as it refracts through glasses
so they've developed as the things like
lenses and so on you know very crude
things and I think at the same time the
Chinese or perhaps earlier the Chinese
developed similar things but the only
thing is that you know Greeks had better
recording methods and also they were
more open so we I can actually tell what
was going on so any case out of all this
is a picked an example that was a
precursor to the Strategic Defense
Initiative that President Reagan have
put forth in the eighties in any case my
competitor Turkey made this he he
figured out how to use giant parabolic
mirrors in order to take sunlight and
focus it on enemy sales so he said any
miss upon fire the enemy in that case
was the Romans so that was against the
first military application of optics
anyways so then the sort of the Middle
Ages came through and like all other
sciences optics disappeared intended to
recovered there shortly after the
Renaissance and you know Newton I guess
he was working on everything so he did
develop say a theory of light which was
based on the fact that light is a
particle at the same time another fellow
Huygens he developed a wave theory of
light and the two were you know fighting
well Newton won that fight because he
happened to be the good boy of the
establishment he was actually it served
professor at Cambridge so you know that
had very significant success that had a
lot of significance in the outcome of
that fight in any case and then you know
for 200 years later people realize that
the wave theory is also correct even
though the sort of particle theory also
seems to be correct yeah
[Laughter]
okay well make a note so so in any case
a Yank observed interference of light so
that it was clear that light is a wave
and then max will actually solve that
light is essentially an electromagnetic
field so then the wave network was not
in doubt but of course the duality
remained and explained until people
developed quantum mechanics and then as
a Seth was saying yesterday wave
particle duality actually did get
explained in a very nice way but quantum
mechanics did not only achieve that the
fact that people started thinking about
light as particles and discrete energy
energy levels and so on
it led to the development of several
optical devices okay before I get to
that let me let me show an example where
optics was enabling for a fundamental
advance in physics you may know that
people before Einstein they didn't know
how fields are transformed so they
didn't know for example how can the
gravity from the Sun affect the earth so
that the earth is stuck to rotate around
the Sun so they were hypothesizing ether
and all kinds of strange things then
optics allowed Michelson invented the
interferometer and he used optics in
order to show that this ether theory was
actually incorrect and this week's
actually I'm not sure if what I'm saying
is totally true but probably it was a
big stimulation for Einstein to develop
special relativity so you know so far
optics has been kind of a kind of a
mintue it to itself to develop you know
optical devices yet here we see optics
enabling the fundamental advance in
physics actually one of the major
advances in this century now in addition
einstein who was melt for a very smart
fellow so he worked on other things as
well so he developed the theory of
spontaneous emission which was used
later let's jump one bullet here which
was used laser and so he which was later
in order for the invention of the laser
so believe it or not time stein was
instrumental in that yet it was a
physicist
count who actually came up with the idea
for a microwave oscillator
oops I hope you didn't die here there we
go okay so she called it maser
and a few years later he actually
figured out that the same can work for a
light the same idea and then the laser
was developed was invented actually I
should probably go through this videos
this guy this is Archimedes this is
Newton this guy here is Maxwell Einstein
everybody knows him then pounce is this
fellow here these two guys are two
instrumental figures in quantum
mechanics this is plunk on the left and
sliding ER in the middle yeah all right
so in fact counts actually after he
invented the laser he became a member of
the MIT faculty and he was the Provost
for a few years I do know that actually
did you know that I found it when I was
reading his noble biography anyway yeah
so now amazingly before the laser was
invented there was a Hungarian fellow in
England working for I believe it was
Oxford but correct me if I'm wrong who
invented the technique - - which called
holography who's actually allowed the
simultaneous recording of amplitude and
phase of the light so of course at the
time
lasers did not exist through the phase
of the light was not a very well-defined
thing but so Gabor in originally
pictured microwaves as a domain for
application of his technique but of
course Wednesday leg once the laser was
invented then holography all of a sudden
became a big deal so that's my favorite
bullet because first of all I work in
holography and also Gabor was awarded
the Nobel Prize in 1971 which is the
year that I was born all right so and
the advantage actually have been
continuing optics has been used for a
tremendous range of applications hussar
will go through the next slide but also
has been enabling very fundamental
advances in science for example you may
have heard of Stephen troupe which
invented the something called optical
tweezer and Ian saw this an optical
tweezers in the laboratory today anyways
- did this in the Bell Labs in 1983 and
a few years later he also won the Nobel
Prize
another fellow who's I omitted
shamefully is
Bloomberg in who was a professor at
Harvard right up the street and he
essentially developed nonlinear optics
which allow us to do fantastic things
like very short pulses of the order of
duration of femtoseconds and and to
start the very and usual light metal
interactions that otherwise are not
possible and she also went to nobel
prize in the eighties a balloon alright
so I hope that the only reason I put up
this slide and I spent a big chunk of my
talk on it is to emphasize how optics
and information trade a sort of play
even in the fundamental level for the
mental science now science is a lot of
fun but what about applications in life
where you know optics can change the
life of people well nowadays well of
course the field is now called optical
engineering right it's actually making
things using light instead of only
studying things so I would not repeat
yesterday's the physics only talk about
things as I say that physicists only
study things because I am a little bit
of a physicist myself all right
so ok so bananas let's see what optics
can do to change society so I sort of
classified applications of optics into
four major categories and put some
examples for each one of those now those
of you invest in the stock market know
that if a company has optics in their
name or their description is a definite
buy
so the reason is because of
communications it's a communication
which is the major application of
engineering nowadays it's not an
understatement and there are all these
optical devices that enable it of course
there is also wireless communications
which is a different field and is also
very important in a very high growth
area but it's also electromagnetic
anyways so in the optics area
semiconductor lasers fiber optics
optical routers optical devices to
distribute optical signal I mean signals
right now between major nodes but very
soon all the way down to your to your
house to your sidewalk
they're a big deal and there's also even
more advanced things like quantum
communications that Seth was describing
yesterday which are also based on the
use of optics and of course this is not
commercial yet but it could be in 10 20
years who knows another big application
of area of optics is data storage you
all have used the CDs and DVDs
nowadays you know how fantastic it is
the DVD you can watch movies and listen
to commentary and blah blah blah
this is magneto-optical discs which
actually failed in the market market but
they remain holographic memories could
try to compete for their for their space
in the market and all these technologies
actually enabled to high-capacity
storage now the most traditional
application of optics is of course
sensors whereby sensors I mean
everything that has to do with imaging
the classical telescopes by not rulers
microscopes digital cameras analog
cameras hybrid cameras whatever and
there's other sort of more exotic things
like displacement sensors which can be
used again for a number of measurements
price or you know deflection and so on
and so forth
and some of these are very classical
interferometers have been known since
young in the 17th century this is a more
recent developed the atomic force
microscope which is based on optical
measurement to displacement and so on
and so forth and so these are sort of
general areas of application but this
were also the biomedical which is
nowadays one of again one of the major
application areas for actually any kind
of engineering and we have all kinds of
fiber-optic endoscope so optical
coherence tomography confocal microscopy
and so on and so forth for diagnostics
and discovery finally last but not least
is this place yet another area where
optics optics has been traditionally
very important probably the first
display was a device called camera
obscura which is actually a very nasty
thing it's probably the first spying
device it allows you to look into a
remote area if you put the lenses
appropriately the remote area just kept
image somewhere in your room so you can
spy on people across the street or
something
in any case nowadays you have liquid
crystal projectors like is it liquid
crystal or MEMS doesn't know anyways so
people use liquid crystals and MEMS to
make projectors like this one we have
virtual reality displays that turbines
the gained an optics laser Souls and
probably the most important is the use
of lasers to process material so you
could do very traditional things like
material welding material you know
combined materials and so on but you can
also bully photographers Popkin Delta
Ocean coast areas telling us yesterday
the reason we have
computers and transistors and so on and
so forth is optical lithography there's
no doubt about it
well joy is trying to change all that
but so far this is what we have and of
course laser said there is another big
deal all right let me tell you a little
bit the things that I do in the optical
engineering lab at MIT first of all has
to tell you that my background is here
my background is an optical memories but
well after I came here I figured I
should do something else to just keep my
interest alive so I spread out into all
these areas so that now I'm working very
heavily in communications my sort of my
most recent project is how to fabricate
something called photonic bandgap
materials now you probably have not
heard of what the photonic band appeared
but let me tell you that it's a class of
the materials that allows you to do very
strange things with light I mean one of
the things that you can do is you can
have like light make a 90-degree turn
without losing any of it so you can have
light turn 90 degrees and 100 percent of
the light energy actually does turn so
unfortunately all these fantastic things
so far happen only in the computers of
over in simulations so we're working in
my lab on actually how making it happen
for real so every excited about that we
also jumped into the optical
communications I don't know how to call
it the bandwagon so we have a some
activity on optical MEMS were making
actually a wavelength router using
optical MEMS and this is continuation
with a micro technology lab and Marty's
MIT a quarter of my activities and
sensors and imaging so have a have a
project called collective vision which
is about equip in a very large number of
robots with an equal number of valid
chip very individually stupid sensors
now when I say how can a camera be
stupid well if you look at the camera if
your camcorder has 640 by 480 pixels or
some something like that now try to look
through a camera with 10 by 10 pixels
you will actually see nothing so that's
what I call a stupid camera yet if you
put all these cameras together all these
little stupid cameras it turns out that
you can get a very high resolution image
of the environment nevertheless and even
more if you distribute the sensors a
proper
they say in this room you can get a
three-dimensional picture of the
environment where your noses actually
can stick out to the image this kind of
thing and so we're working on how to
adapt the sensors and make them and make
them get the best images given the
circumstances and we're also working on
visual learning on how how can use the
information to train systems to
artificial systems to perform something
now the something that the systems we
develop our performance is pretty
horrible actually we're working for
therefore so what they want us to do is
locate targets and well I will let you
imagine whether they do the targets but
in any case there's a great deal of
commercial applications for this
technology for example in entertainment
you could imagine mounting these sensors
on the legs of soccer players or
basketball players and the players moved
through the field you can actually use
the information returned by the sensors
in order to reconstruct the game in 3d
so then you know you're sitting then in
your virtual reality room and you
actually feel as if you were in the
basketball court these are the kinds of
commercial applications that could get
enabled by this technology all right let
me not take too much too long the thing
that that will actually talk about today
is another kind of imaging which I call
four dimensional imaging and I call it
saw because we're trying to image
volumes so by volume I mean really X Y Z
the same kind of image that you get from
MRI for example and in addition spectrum
so we're trying to image the color of
light now you say well why how is this
different than the camera or perhaps two
cameras well here's the difference if
you have one camera first of all you get
a planar projection of space so that 2d
and also the camera does not get real
color information it just gets red green
and blue RGB real card information would
really give you the the intensity the
relative intensity as a function of
wavelength so it's really new dimension
now like every instrument it it needs
for an application being at MIT we found
a fantastic one some colleagues in
cognitive science they're interested in
building in making cultures of neurons
so you know what they do is they cut up
the brain of the mouse and the
take a slice of neurons they put them on
a chip and then they activate it
electrically so there's a strong need in
order to monitor the dynamics of these
neurons we would like to actually be
able to monitor their activity and this
is what the sensor will be doing so
we're very excited about that we're also
working on interferometric surface
metrology with applications such as
corneal topographer measuring the shape
of your eye and so on and so forth but
again I will not have time to talk about
all right let me motivate a little bit
why we want 3-d and 4-d vision as the
world there's no doubt that we're very
strongly visual animals we rely on
vision very much and argument about it
is that you know blind people are very
severely handicapped right so they if
you look at the brain which are probably
our most sophisticated instrument that
Nature gave us a very big part of it is
devoted to vision yet the the ability of
our brain took to acquire the
environment is still kind of handicapped
why because the sensors that you have
it's only two of them and they are you
know pretty much like cameras very
sophisticated cameras we know with very
huge and how it called dynamic range and
so on and so forth and very good
resolution yet if you look at this
picture you become very severe as a
severely perplexed because there's
actually an impossible picture and the
reason you get perplexed okay there's
nothing wrong with it
it's a planar drawing it can look
whatever it want yet your brain tries to
interpret it in 3d and you realize that
it's impossible and there's many many
other examples of illusions that saw the
deficiency of our brains to process 3d
information which is not inherent in our
brain in fact it is just because of the
limitations of the senses or to have the
limitations of our eyes so biometric
systems are good but well you know when
people were trying to make airplanes for
many many centuries they were trying to
imitate parrots and you know they kept
falling so they would fail well at some
point they invented you know jet engine
and propellers and then you know all of
a sudden planes became successful yet
planes still have to have wings so my
point is that you know it's good to
imitate nature but up to some point our
ingenuity can actually overcome nature
and perform better not because we're
smarter than natural
because natural perhaps didn't have the
needs that we have developed for
ourselves
anyways so when we develop an imaging
system we actually try to develop
sensors that can overcome the
limitations of our eyes at least this is
what I do so we try to develop sensors
that can capture the environment in 3d
and give us more information now
information is a key here because if you
think about what does an imaging system
do well it forms an image but what is an
image worth image is worth as much as
many questions you can answer about the
object so the way I post it it refers
exactly to Indian formation that my
system transfers between the object and
the observer and the space where this
transfer occurs can have several
dimensions the typical typical camera is
2-dimensional Plus this RGB color then
you can think of various volumetric
imaging techniques like you know
tomography pet and MRI and all these
things you can think of 2d imaging
spectroscopy which is a very new field
you can actually buy these devices now
but you couldn't buy them three or four
years ago and so that's N equals three
when you talk about imaging volume and
spectrum at the same time so now this is
the generalization of this image in
spectroscopy to volumes then we go into
N equals four a four dimensional space
now people have been working for a long
time on imaging techniques that allow
you to resolve that for minutes all
right
so I'll take I figured four minutes is
the standard for
I should've asked two minutes later
thank you
all right so I will accelerate a bit so
so the triangulation is essentially the
way we use to figure depth now
triangulation is very nice but it limits
you to image and surface objects opaque
objects if you can actually look through
objects then regulation won't work I
mean it will work but it will give you
very poor results so there's other
techniques like coherence imaging which
I will not talk into but if you look at
the system here you realize that there's
no lens so it's a very strange image the
technique that still believe me it still
works many people are doing it and yet
does not use any lenses at all
let's confocal microscopy hood
fortunately my colleague Peter and
enable and friends he talked yesterday
so I don't have to explain it now the
the point is that if you look at
traditional optical systems where you
have a train of lenses and at the back
you have either the retina of the viewer
or a piece of film then actually we're
actually helpless
there's no way to do depth imogen what
we can do is we can augment optical
systems with well guess what information
technology will computers and so all the
systems are the shot before
triangulation interferometry and and
confocal microscopy they're based on the
fact that the image information is
collected by computer and then post
processed in order to acquire the volume
all right let me skip the two and I was
just going to say that the reason I did
all this is because as a kid I loved
Star Wars so I wanted to develop things
that you know you can be like r2d2 I'm
not doing exactly that I'm just doing
the revision but anyways okay so let me
tell you a little bit about the tools
that I'm using whether use is something
called volume Holograms now most of you
know what the hologram is you see them
in this place at airports museums and so
on in fact the best display in the world
is just one block down the street down
must having you if you go to the MIT
Museum which I believe is open on Sunday
you can see the best collection of
columns in the world most of those made
by my colleague in the Media Lab Steven
Bentham okay so the person here is the
inventor of holography dennis gabor
sitting next to his hologram now the
gabor invented they're known as thin
Holograms at least now who call them
thin Holograms and they will call them
so well because they're thin only few
optical wavelengths thick and their
property is that if you rotate you are a
point of view the image also rotates and
as a result you get a different
perspective so the hologram appears to
be 3d and in fact you know because you
have two eyes each eye looks at the
different angle so therefore you you you
have the illusion that the image with
your contact is three-dimensional well
the volume Holograms do not have this
advantage well when you illuminate it at
the correct angle then you get their
construction to come out when you tilt
the angle a little bit you get nothing
to come out so this sounds like a
serious handicap but it doesn't able to
do something it doesn't have you to use
the hologram as a matched filter let me
explain what I mean by matched filter
let's say that the hologram is recorded
by a very simple optical wave a point
source so you take the point source you
pass it through a lens to collimate it
and then you use a reference wave on top
so the to interfere inside the volume
like a little tube and they form a
hologram
well now as I said before if the
hologram is reconstructed by the
appropriate angle which in this case is
horizontal then it will actually deflect
a very significant amount of light and
we call this black matching so that's
fine however if we defocus the point
that could construct the hologram then
all kinds of new angular components get
into the picture now the central one
still reconstruct slide but the off-axis
components do not and therefore you can
you what the hologram does is discard a
point source that has been the focus so
so that's that's the basic property that
we use in order to to utilize Holograms
as imaging elements so if you compare a
focused point source and the now to
focus point source the focus point
source makes it through the out-of-focus
point source does not make it through so
this now becomes a little bit
reminiscent to a confocal microscope
that Peter was describing yesterday
where if you put a pinhole in order to
pass a point a focused point source
through the system but when the point
source is out of focus then the pinhole
discards it so the hologram does
actually the operation of a pinhole and
we'll call it the black pinhole
all right let me let me point out a
couple of things first of all much
filter
better I will only take 30 seconds so
much building is better because it is
actually fit suit suits the propagation
of light better the problem is that 3d
scan is still required so in the sense
the whole operation of this device he
still is a confocal microscope and one
of the potential problems is that the
hologram does not deflect all the light
that comes through you lose a little bit
of light so then you know you realize
that this could be a problem yet now who
can make Holograms that that around 100
percent perhaps 95 or 90% so that's not
a problem anymore let me not go through
the details this is a kind of image that
you get using this device this this
imaging device this is a piece of wafer
where there was a small trench and the
trench appears black here why because
the trench was out of focus therefore it
did not give signal at the detector the
trench you know the surface gives a high
signal because it is in focus and so on
and so forth let me go not to go through
those is very interesting but but I
don't have time now what we're working
on right now is to generalize this
technique in order to acquire spectral
and volumetric information so why do we
want to do this is in order to be able
to image fluorescent tags which allow us
to monitor various biological effects so
the facts could be either applied fields
that change the spectrum with a
fluorescence spectrum or it could be the
formation sort could be chemical
reactions or whatever but this way we
can monitor neurons who can make on
monitor proteins reacting and so on and
we can do it simultaneously in volume in
space so again I don't have time to get
into the details I just tell you that
this happens to a volume called Graham
recorded and set up in an appropriate
way with a little bit of auxiliary
optics down here what it allows us to do
is image resolution volumes when another
volume is in 4d so it has DX Delta X
Delta Y Delta Z and Delta Lambda so we
need to come up with the name of this
the 2d name is pixel the 3d name is
voxel we didn't have a 4d name so we
invented taxol so it allows you to image
textiles that are as big as 1 micron by
1 micron by 1 micron in space and 1
nanometer in wavelength so that's pretty
good and we can also do this in one shot
so different slices of the object
get them up into detector simultaneously
and I will not say anything else because
my friend Seth here will have a heart
attack so so I will spare you
okay so I finished my research talk if I
if I may let me go through very briefly
through the curriculum changes that we
made for optics I keep in fact there is
a reason I did this like last night
urgently because it's a very important
question all these things all these
techniques are very new and in fact you
know not only in mechanical engineering
but also in other fields even physicists
sometimes falter in these in these
things so it's very important to to
provide the students with a set of
classes that introduce them in the play
in the proper way and again I'm going to
refer to Popkin del Toro's and yesterday
who said that well you know within three
weeks in his freshman year he learnt
enough genetic optics to do lithography
but a lot of things unfortunately or
fortunately actually because they keep
us in business but the unfortunate thing
is that geometric optics is not enough
so you know the students need to learn a
little bit more ok so optics has been
slowly creeping into an the graduate
curriculum who have this introductory
measurement instrumentation class where
who have been developing at least one
new optics experiment and we plan to
sort of make it a permanent one because
in this class the experiments change
with every time but in case we plan to
make this permanent there's a proposal
that is circulating now among the
faculty to the engineer our entire
instrumentation sequence so six seven
one is the first one and then we have
six seven two there's a proposal to add
the new one two six seven three and if
this happens there will be enough room
to put more optics experiments and not
only sort of mundane things like
interferometry but also more spectacular
things like atomic force microscopy and
so on
now there's a very extended list of
graduate courses - seven and seven will
be offered as a regular course start
next year
it has been offered as a special clause
a course for awhile there's an optical
image in class that Peter saw is offered
in the spring Ian Hunter informed us
they both offer advanced intro mister
instrumentation classes which are not
optics oriented but they contain optics
experiments so
that's the difference the first two are
actually optics centered whereas the
others have optics sort of in person and
this hammer who initiated also a summer
professional class which I will not say
anything more otherwise else I will
sound like a Salesman and at last I
finished thank you
[Applause]